now from there and these basic results
there's three kinds of variations on the
theme every trig integral and derivative
is really just one of these kinds of um
what's the looking for when you've got
what you've got I am in music when
you've got like a theme and it just very
what's it called what is it is it a no
it's another one before it's a movement
I don't know it's that it's the same
kind of idea and you just see it dressed
up in different instruments and
different tunes and tempos and that kind
of thing but it's still these three so
the first one is channel or since we're
thinking about integration really it's
reverse channel right example no simple
one the derivative of say sine 5x what
is it it's changing right what is it
it's by five cos Phi X isn't it because
you differentiate the inside which gives
you five and then you differentiate the
outside which is sine it goes to cost no
problem okay
so therefore if I were to integrate 5
cos 5 I would go back exactly where I
came from with the exception of the
constant okay but you know often you
won't have that five out the front
you'll see this what's the difference
between these two lines it's it's just
that this line is five times smaller
than this line isn't it so therefore the
right hand side should be the same why
don't I have to divide the constant by
five because it just will be another
constant exactly right so it doesn't
matter it's still just C great now this
chain rule it comes up in some unusual
places you wouldn't expect for instance
if I asked you what the integral of tan
was you might think why didn't appear
over here it's kind of like wannabe
standard results right the answer is its
cuz it involves for first channel the
question is what I've can't remember i I
may can remember mentioning this before
okay so let me try and help you
by writing this tan as sign over cause
I'm pretty sure I didn't mention this
but I think it was a bit ahead of time
okay now have a look at this I know that
doesn't look like it's much more helpful
than this but it really is it really is
let me do one more thing slap a minus
sign at the front you're like why would
I do that
it's so that I can get them minus sign
on the numerator now have a look at that
believe it or not this is a form that
you're familiar with you've worked at
this before this numerator in this
denominator they're not just random I
got that negative sign there for a
reason
how are they related this this really
negative sign is the derivative of
Connor's isn't it this is in the form
sorry F dash on F okay now this is I
really should've said reversed hmm what
function do you differentiate and you
land on that when you use chain rule and
the answer is a work function right if
you were to differentiate log of F
that's what we give you this so
therefore if I integrate I mean that's
what all of this is about all of your
integrals are built off of derivatives
okay I actually don't want this space I
need over here if we were to think about
what kind of more function is going to
come from it would be log F which is
down there in the denominator so it's
minus negative log of cos x plus our
constant okay
and of course the great thing about all
integration questions is you can check
it by differentiating right and you'd go
okay F - negative sign another negative
cancels that and then over f it works
let me get back to ten okay so these are
the kinds of things you see all of these
ones which are just um these ones where
it's just a constant a constant
coefficient that gets chucked in these
are so common they actually get given to
you and your tables standard entry rules
okay let's say the integral would cause
a X with respect to X is one over a sine
ax and then the integral of sine ax you
get the idea okay but they're all very
similar to each other
like I said variations on a theme okay
now being this is true and you spent a
big part of your life thinking about how
to manipulate different trig functions
together the next kind of variation is
ones that require identities okay wait
let me do one more before I get to that
well we will get to this in a second but
let me just give you one more reverse
chain rule suppose I gave you this okay
now you have the advantage of me telling
you again this is reversed chainable how
could you go about it can anyone see it
right immediately off the bat anyway now
that that's fine that's okay if you if
you can't do that yet that's a signal to
you that reverse chain rule is the kind
of question that you should approach by
substitution okay of course eventually
like these kinds of questions you think
I don't need to do let u equal 5x I can
do that in my head but when you kind of
do it yet you should substance you what
kind of things should I introduce for
you
what should I pick sorry I think that's
a good choice okay I'll ask you in a
second why you chose that why do I what
I do with this now the way have chosen
you differentiate which gives you cause
know what
I could make DX a subject or
alternatively I could see that because I
know where I'm gonna use this right
I can see look there's our cause an X DX
right there so I can kind of just say
this kind of okay for really intents and
purposes that we're working with it'll
work just fine
so therefore what's this integral really
equal to all right all right
that'd be you
squared do you actually that's it isn't
it
right so therefore that's you cubed on
three plus you're constantly sorry it's
a day which is just thank you I can't
hold on let me just come back a step why
did you choose sign and not cause why
did you choose so because it's the one
that's squared right so in some sense is
that's how you know this is the function
that's important and this is just coming
along because it's the derivative of
this on the inside okay